[موسيقى]
الله
الموسيقى في سلطنه عمان جزء اصيل في شخصيه
الانسان العماني طاهره جمال من اشهر عازفي
اله الكمان في السلطنه حيث بدات التعلم
على هذه الاله من دون نعومه اظافرها
بدايه الموسيقى وانا بالعمر 11 سنه
الوالد اعرض لي اني انا اقدم في
الفرقه السلطانيه
وكان هناك يعني يحتاجوا فرقه خاصه نسائيه
وف انا وخواتي قدمنا فيها هذه الفرقه
والحمد لله جهه الاختيار فيني انا وايضا
همم خوات عندي الاثنين
[موسيقى]
طاهره عضوه في فرقه دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
وشاركت في العديد من المحافل الدوليه
فين مشاركات كم شركه في افتتاحيه الملعب
المونديالي في قطر 2017
وايضا في مشاركه مع الفنان جهاد عقل
العازف الكمال العالمي في دار الاوبرا
السلطانيه
[موسيقى]
رائد الفارسي الذي فقد بصره لكن بصيرته
الفنيه اثرت المشهد الموسيقي في سلطنه
عمان
[موسيقى]
بدات منذ الطفوله المبكره باستخدام
الحالات عرفت
النوت الموسيقيه بطريقه طبعا برايل لتعلم
بها المكفوفين
ولقاعات والمقامات الموسيقيه كل هذا
ساعدني في صقر الموهبه الموسيقيه بعد ذلك
[موسيقى]
العربيه